welcome this is a game I played
back in the under-16 chess olympiad
between me and Grand Master Shimin off I
don't know if you guys have heard of him
he's he's one of the top members of the
map of the Webster team that's actually
situated here in in Saint Louis very
very strong Russian Grandmaster back in
the days I was high rated on him I
cannot dream of that anymore
no this was this was the Olympics team
Olympics under-16 played in Novi Sad in
2006 I think so in the 21st century so I
opened up with e4 this used to be my
main weapon up until maybe five years
ago when I when I decided I cannot keep
up with with sharp theory and I and I
went to d4 try to grab a more strategic
approach to chess and things turned out
quite well but I was I was a very feared
efore player I could say I was losing
maybe one game per year and then winning
a lot of a lot of games against strong
opposition so lady for c5 c6 okay how do
how do we call this this variation of
the Sicilian Sicilian can actually I
think it's written right so yes it's a
Sicilian current variation Queen c7 and
here I played Bishop e2 obviously the
main lines are Bishop d3 or Bishop e3
and then and then extreme extremely
complicated variations after Knight f6
Bishop before the theory's is is quite
massive here and I didn't really want to
enter those lines especially as I
mentioned that was a pretty lazy guy and
I wasn't really
learning theory as as much as I should
have
especially when I was here so I pray we
should be to a more tame approach b5
castle this should be seven alright so
what is he threatening and what are my
options
his Stratos is to play B for absolutely
and I move my knight he takes my e4 pawn
that's about it pretty basic threat
nothing nothing complicated there how
can I defend Bishop f3 is one of them
absolutely anything else
and even even more direct approach I
could III could say he's 83 just stop
him altogether from playing b4 but in
general I just didn't like play moves
like a tree I felt like they kind of
their kind of a loss of tempo so I
wasn't a big fan of those type of moves
back in the days
anything else I decided to be a little
bit creative so may mmm Queen d3 Queen
d3 is definitely an idea but I don't
think I want my Queen der because in
general after Queen d3 he would also
play Knight of six reinforcing the
threat and the problem is that this
Queen might become the target of this
Knight potentially these six 97-95 the
queen is not that badly placed er
because I can always swing it maybe on
g3 or on h3 to Tyler to try to kind of
bring it into the attack but yeah it's a
it's not the work is not the type of
move I wanted to play so something else
I played rook e1
he played before okay what was my idea
behind this rookie one move I suddenly
decided to kind of shift gears and stop
my team approach sort of this is just
kind of our elite that you guys could
follow so how did I go what did I play
ideas what are my options guys 94 91 or
95 or 95 might be one is definitely not
something that I wanted to play he if I
allow before I definitely don't want to
bring back my night to be one night of
94 is another placement of the night
that I kind of try to avoid at all times
because I don't really see a way to
continue after that so I played 95 that
was that was my whole point of playing
rookie 1 in the first place I told you
some some sort of creative flow hit me
no no no no no I I mean I I never played
actually Bishop e2 in my life I you I
was sometimes prepared but then I
decided to play Bishop e2 because I was
facing a very strong opponent I didn't
want to fall under his theoretical
preparation so on the spot I decided to
play Bishop e2 take take
and and now he I'm having some serious
threats right I'm threatening to play
maybe Bishop takes a six maybe Bishop f3
simply just kind of give that check put
my knight on f5 Corral my pieces around
his King and hope for the best basically
so he played Bishop c5 was the point of
this move
ye-yeah 97 is is definitely something
that he has in mind
there's another reason why he played
this Bishop c5 more what about just
simply hiding his King on this side
because if he goes on da then he's
always going to stay in the center and
potentially after he plays d6 I will
always have checks on c6 and stuff like
that
in general the much safer place for the
king is on FA yeah so that's part of his
his plan with Bishop c5 I played Bishop
f3
I don't think Bishop takes a 6 despite
the fact that it wins the pawn it slows
me down a lot because now he plays King
f8 and I don't really want to exchange
pieces that's not my goal if I have to
withdraw my Bishop then I'm losing a lot
of temples and one one tempo is is
enough to completely lose all my done
dynamics in the position and then I will
simply blare be a piece down so I played
Bishop f3 King f8 what now how to
continue the attack Queen e2 that's a
very direct approach I agree the problem
with this is he's simply going to go
Knight f6
Queeny to is definitely something I have
in mind in the future
but I didn't want to hurry with that
so I played something else
mmm
this six this six simple just doesn't
work because he's going to take with
with the bishop now I'm going to take me
beyond b7 but he takes and I didn't
really get much in return for that pawn
yeah and now he also has this square for
his night before he didn't with my pawn
on d5 I was controlling the center quite
quite nicely right now after 96 once
again he's going to be a piece up and my
position would crumble very very fast so
d6 is not the move I played 95
absolutely Knight a5 yes that's that's
exactly what I played attacking the g7
pawn kind of getting closer and closer
to that King and also I have a clear
threat what is that
this X is my trap yeah this is this is
my trade and he has to play one to
defend against it he has only one move
to play the six himself yeah but after
he plays this move d6 at least this
bishop is kind of cut out from his
defense yeah
and also this d6 pawn might become a
target for me and and from now on this
is kind of what I focused on the d6 pawn
but it's not that easy to do that
because he has a very very strong
defender in that Bishop on c5 and I am
also fighting time if I play slow moves
I'm going to be in big trouble
he's going to play 97 Knight of 6 maybe
rooky 8 start exchanging some some
pieces and I can basically resign or he
can play something like 97-95
clogged the e-file once again piece up
not a lot of compensations so here I
kind of had to stop and think for a long
time and I would say this is probably
one of the moves and the ideas I'm kind
of most proud of of of those years those
formative years if you're at home stop
it
try to give some some thought to it I
thought maybe for 30 40 minutes again
again I knew it was coming I knew it was
solid and I forgot and I forgot to turn
it off I do have tea absolutely it is
tea time so what to do
again try to remember what I said my
targets are Bishop f4 is definitely the
first move that counts comes into your
mind as if starting about the position
the problem with this move is that he's
probably going to go Knight d7 he is in
fact threatening to play 95 and that
exchange and even after that playing d6
is not going to help me that much
especially if I need to give up my dark
square bishop so Bishop f4 I just it i I
was probably very close to playing it
but I just stopped and and forced myself
to think a little bit deeper than that
it's a very natural move is the move
that in a blitz game you would make
instantly but it's not it is not the
correct approach how to get rid of this
guy that's the main question
if this wouldn't be here he would be
completely lost because he doesn't have
any other defender on the d6 square
Bishop f4 Bishop takes d6 basically he
can resign so try to craft a plan to
accomplish that and try to be creative
in that process because it's there is no
direct way of doing that do you want to
exchange the bishops with Bishop III
that would get rid of the Bishop on c5
but it would also get rid of your
attacker of your only attacker on dark
dark dark squares and that is your your
bishop so that's not the right way
Bishop III is not the right way c3 is a
very interesting absolutely what's your
point
yep
no c3 c3 is definitely one of one of the
top choices and this idea with giving up
one of these two points actually as you
guys will see a tree was my move and
then playing before that will distract
this Bishop and despite the fact that it
will only move him one square away he's
going to give me a very very important
diagonal and that would be this one and
I will be able to bring my Queen in the
center centralize the Queen which will
create very very unpleasant attacks for
him the problem with c3 is that he's
probably going to go a five and if I
take take I didn't really accomplish
that much on the other hand with a three
if you place a five I get rid of one of
his defenders and that will be the rook
on a a I also put his Bishop on a very
very passive position on a given all
that his his best move would still have
been a five this was his best move and
he should have went for it but White has
quite quite good compensation here yeah
because of the fact that I can just do
something like this for example Queen e2
and now you don't have this annoying
move ninety-seven defending with the
rook on yay right because I simply take
on a8 you take with the bishop Queen e8
and that's checkmate so I get a lot of a
lot of play here he took on a tree which
is kind of like the natural way to be
honest I don't think he saw before
coming which was my move I think he
won't he expected me to take on a three
probably just thought that my idea was
to put my bishop on b2 and find the
diagonal for my bishop but he would have
repelled that quite easily with
something like Knight 97 the 95
quite annoying yeah once again this
bishop is an extremely good defender so
here I played before now he has his
committed he has to take everything if
he goes to Bishop a7 after Bishop a4 he
can resign
nothing defending the d6 pawn anymore so
he took him before how to continue and
what was his plan because he surely
tried to calculate and he and he was
able to calculate pretty far what did
what did he think his resource was his
defensive resource
I don't know I haven't does he
so let's calculate Queen D for Bishop
takes II 1 Queen takes g7 King e8 then
maybe I can just simply take on h8 and
then his night on g8 is falling can he
defend at night on g8 not really and
also his King is very very exposed after
that yeah so after Queen D for Bishop
take c1 wasn't his planned resource to
something else
Bishop's III absolutely and that's
exactly what happened
so queen the poor Bishop to c3 now it's
a yeah it's a pretty funny position
because all my all my heavy pieces are
under attack yet I'm doing pretty well
that's especially because of the fact
that this d6 pawn once again if that
falls if I manage to take something with
something on d6 supported my by my
bishop then his his position completely
collapses so what should I do now what
are my options and which ones look more
most appealing to you guys queen g4 is
an interesting one no after Queen g4 I'm
actually going to take on a1 yeah I can
still take that take that rook and keep
my Bishop on the diagonal that's an
option but it's probably not not good
enough also maybe I'm not even maybe I'm
not even forced to take on a1 because
maybe if you take I take on a3 and then
once again you have some problem on d6
but in this position maybe I can prepare
my defense on the dark squares and play
97 now if you take on a3 I put I simply
play 95 clock the diagonal and then the
d6 pawn becomes quite safe yeah so it's
not decisive enough Queen g4 is not
aggressive enough
are you okay Queen f4 let's try let's
try it out okay I'm going to try to do
the same thing I think and just play
Knight d7 do I want to do that let's try
it yeah yeah yeah and if I'm not giving
anything extraordinary in returned and
probably it's not a good idea
so Queen a4 it's an interesting try
absolutely it is probably not the best
I played Queen III which okay creates a
battery on the e-file but most
importantly keeps keep some some
connection to the c3 bishop so now if he
tries to play Knight d7 Bishop a bishop
takes a 395 the c3 Bishop is under
attack right so I can simply take the
bishop and as game over that's part of
the reason I played Queen e3 but him
being a sneaky guy he had some resources
up his sleeves so he played the move
Knight ISA
was the point of this move it looks
pretty stupid because he it just puts
the night in in track but if I take it
then he's simply going to take my rook
and this Knight is actually very very
bad place now if I take back he's going
to take my knight on me seven he has a
tremendous advantage it's it's a rout
Cup yeah I'm not going to be able to
recover from that so this kind of
surprised me I I don't think I saw 97
anticipated this move
I was lucky though to have some some
aces up my sleeve as well so how did I
continue if I if I take with the Queen
once again the exchange of the Queen's
is definitely not going to do it for me
that's not something that I can recover
from once again so Queenie 7 is out of
the question what is pretty much the
other move that remains Bishop takes a
tree absolutely Bishop takes a tree and
then he played Bishop to e5 this was his
plan all along
yeah
what no what are my options how can I
can I increase the pressure anymore on
that d6 porn right then I have to do
something quickly because he's
threatening to take my knight on f5 that
was kind of his strategy as well he
wanted to develop his species with
temple putting pressure on me so that I
cannot kind of place my pieces on the
right squares and mount the pressure he
wanted to get rid of that that annoying
attacking those annoying attacking
possibilities as soon as possible and my
knight on f5 is one of my main pieces my
main collaborator into the attack so
what to do
and as a backstory I was well I was
actually I will tell it to you after I
find a move because that would kind of
give away the idea candidate moves guys
this is the easiest way not to forget
about anything so 90-87 is definitely
one of them
I'm going to take with the Queen because
I cannot take with the night because of
Queen takes e5 and after that I'm not
really sure I have a good way to to
continue a good way to justify my huge
material deficit yeah I mean I can take
on e5 but then he's just going to take
with with the pawn I'm going to take on
his seven that's just going to be an
exchange piece down yeah simply piece
down after Knight xt720 xt720 xt5 not
much not much actually I can still play
d6
but even in this position his his
opponent yeah and that's not enough
that's not enough compensation for me
his king is indeed really exposed but
I'm not sure I can take advantage of it
that easily like for example if I give a
check maybe he can just simply go to e5
no he six if I give another check he's
going to go to f6 then suddenly he kind
of got his species out yeah so this was
definitely one an interesting idea yeah
this was definitely something that I had
to calculate but he didn't satisfy me I
had I was sure I need to find something
better
something to kind of completely finish
him also I'm not sure after 97 maybe he
can just no no taking on a one is
suicidal because of what move 96 exactly
96 and checkmate only 8 is coming he's
going to take Queen e8 so no he's going
to take with the Queen and the variation
we've just analyzed but you're right
that was surely one of the one of the
calculations I made in the position
Queen takes d5 yeah
let's calculate that can I just give a
queen like that Queen takes e5 D takes
e5 and how is that position
I'm a queen down right but I have this
annoying annoying attack on on the a3 FA
diagonal and his King is very very weak
I'm at least going to take one piece
back what is the main what is his main
option after d6
let's say Queen d7 let's say he plays
Queen d7 he just tries to save his queen
yeah how to continue now point xe7
mm-hmm
if he goes King g8 come on no 97
checkmate victory so after hit after I
take on his 7 he's gonna go King GA now
I can just simply take on b7 take
another piece attack the rook everything
is with temple he cannot take on b7
because I promote he goes through k7 and
now there's probably more than one way
of finishing the game here but I think
the easiest one is just to attack the
Queen bring my last piece into the
attack completely lost completely
completely lost
so yeah 25 is actually is actually the
move the move that I made and back story
I promised we were we were having a
dinner after millionaire chess that just
ended like like a few weeks ago and
Shimano was at the table and and somehow
the discussion because we haven't talked
throughout the years we haven't really
kept in touch we weren't friends or
anything like that so so I asked him if
he remembers our game and he was after a
few drinks and he was like you know my
memory is not very good but that is one
game one move that I will never forget
in my life yeah in his Russian accent
Russian thick accent so I was pleased
with that but he took d6
and how how does he try to survive here
what is the only way of of him kind of
continuing the fight continuing the
battle night except five I'm just going
to take on c7 then I'm going to take on
b7 and then game is over
ya know Bishop takes f3 is the only is
the only chance and after D takes c7
yeah where where is he going to move the
night only to c6 because if he moves it
to d7 then I can just simply take the
night back and now his night only 7 his
night only 7 his paint he's he's going
to lose it in one move but with the
knight on c6 at least he keeps contact
with that and despite the fact that it
looks so dominant this is a game that
that kind of only is the position in
which if I lose one tempo I'm actually
going to lose my advantage so he took on
he took I took on f3 what should he play
now
once again try to be as resilient as
possible
what are the problems that he's facing
for once is the is is the pin on the a3
of a diagonal and another one is his
king right so try to make a move to to
improve both of them well to be honest
f6 is kind of the only the only way he
can try for something because after King
g8 I can just simply take on his 7 then
take only 5 and then the knight is lost
once again so another problem that he
has to fight against is this pressure on
the e-file so yeah f6 kind of solves
most of those problems I have to be very
precise here in order to convert my
advantage so let's try to do that I
cannot lose the grip I have to keep him
tied up until the end so what you do
let's okay do you one rook to d1 is
probably winning as well rook a to d1
but I played rookie to d1 because once
again kind of you need to always check
the quality of your pieces what is the
rook only one going to do in the future
not that much while this route could go
where go on the B file and actually try
to penetrate on on the on the B file so
why not keep this rook here and then
just use the other look to to to to go
on d7 so I play rogue do you want King
f7 Knight xe7 rook d7 again keep him
tied up as much as possible
rocky eight
continue
with what we discussed the plan that we
discussed rugby one rupee one now I'm
threatening to go rook b8 divert one of
his defenders he's going he's going to
have to take on b8 I take he takes back
and then the e7 Knight doesn't have a
defense anymore so right now he's going
to lose a piece he played rook c8 and I
played croupier I continue again I I
cannot allow him any moves because his
next move would be King e6 getting out
of that pin and and equalizing the
position but everything was with temple
for example here if he plays King g6 I
do what
a ruby eight I take your rook on d7 that
might be bad might be bad
protec c7 rook takes in seven Bishop
takes e7 and then route b8 and that's it
game over yeah so he doesn't have time
for that
rook c8 rook b8 rook takes e7 rule 57
and we played a few more moves I
converted quite easily I'm a piece up
there's not much conversation for it he
has one point but that's about it
let's just see it till the end
pacifies his roof yeah now his rook is
passive on only a file he has to defend
the only thing I need to do to do right
now is centralized my king and bring my
last piece into into play so I play king
upon h5 Roxy 7 Roxy 6 c4 he was trying
to create some sort of counter play
there but there's not much an after-work
b5 he resigned
yeah because I take only 4 and and and
and that was about it so yeah that was
chess in the 21st century
you